let's go to our caller from the 805 area
codes 805 805 are you there hi hey who's
this it is awesome I appreciate your
show you're pretty cool I had a question
about this whole ad pocalypse thing
people are talking about it seems like
everyone wants to treat these platforms
as if they're actually the public square
when they're not beholding to anybody
but shareholders and advertisers
that's correct currently they're not
right and so I I kind of don't get how I
guess everyone wants it to be that and
expect it to be this neutral platform
but can anyone really pretend that they
are here's the thing here so here here's
my take and not everybody's take is the
same on this for me it is unquestionable
that right now Twitter Facebook YouTube
whoever can have terms and conditions
that restrict the types of speech that
is either allowed or monetizable like
there's no debate whatsoever that as the
law currently stands they can do that
what there's a debate about is should
the law around the regulation of these
companies be changed to consider them
public accommodations in which case they
would not be able to have terms and
conditions that restrict speech beyond
just what is illegal what is caught you
know what is calling for illegal
activity or whatever that's the debate
you're completely right that as it
stands right now like the entire ad
pocalypse thing is because YouTube
doesn't want to lose money and they're
going to make decisions that aren't
actually based on like the political
leanings of individuals who are
reviewing content it's just based on
what is going to prevent brands from
freaking out and pulling out ad money if
you want to change that you need to
designate these platforms public
accommodations and regulate them as such
that makes a lot of sense but the it
seems like introducing regulations that
would allow for any
speech as that it is you know to
speaking out in the world that what
would happen is brands are going to be
freaked out anyway even if it's illegal
they don't want to be associated with
you know potentially hateful speech for
example so that it seems like it that
could be the end almost of that public
square just by virtue of its the problem
with the the business model being so
dependent on ads that can be attacked
for any particular it doesn't matter
what side of the political spectrum
someone's getting attacked from yes just
the ads don't want to be around it
that's exactly right that's exactly
right and in fact my commentary on
today's program says that which is that
I am on the left but I don't need to
take a partisan approach to realize that
this is just about what's going to freak
brands out or not period and we ideally
should sever this relationship between
the media producer and needing the
advertiser to be comfortable with their
content and the way to do that is is is
direct support I'm sorry I'm at a time I
got a run I got I'm gonna let you go we
I wish we had more time to devote to
that but I am going to talk about that
more on the program that does it for
calls today sorry to everybody I didn't
get to but there will be plenty of
opportunities next week to take more
phone calls and hear for more people